now
air force one lands at reed
international airport as president joe
biden the first lady arrived for harry
reid's memorial service they will be
joining a whole host of political
dignitaries gathering to pay their
respects to the late senator
that service is happening tomorrow
morning and will reflect the former
senators immeasurable impact right here
in nevada and really across the country
sasha loftis joining us live from the
smith center with more information sasha
brian tomorrow this building will
transform to a place where people who
knew and loved harry reid can remember
who he was and everything he brought to
nevada
there's no one like him
and never will be again weeks after his
death the world remembers nevada's
fiercest warrior he would not back down
from a fight especially when it involved
nevada harry reid who passed on december
28 at 82 years old was our state's
longest serving senator and as clark
county commissioner tick sagerbloom says
dedicated his life to make it better for
everyone there truly has been no one
more important for nevada than terry
reed those who knew read best will come
together saturday to remember everything
he accomplished and all the lives he
touched
president biden arrived with the first
lady in las vegas friday he and other
prominent political leaders are set to
speak at the memorial at the smith
center former president obama will
deliver his eulogy and a few of reed's
favorite artists carol king and brandon
flowers of the killers will also perform
it's an event no one will ever forget
fitting for a man enshrined in our
nation's history he helped make nevada
what it is today a world class
destination
and the service is set to start at 11
tomorrow morning here at the smith
center and last until about one in the
afternoon plan for some rolling road
closures in the downtown area and really
all around las vegas and some delays at
the airport as the president and those
other prominent political figures come
and go reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now while tomorrow's
ceremony is only open to family and
friends we will stream it online right
here on 8 news now dot com and we will
also air it live right here on
television on channel late tomorrow at
11 a.m